and when President Trump reopened the
government he also called for a
bipartisan committee to attempt to hash
out some border compromise John was
talking about it before February 16th so
why haven't we heard about any progress
here now a member of that committee
Republican representative Tom graves of
Georgia all right congressman any
progress whatsoever and if not don't be
partisan about this what can we what can
we do now to make some progress before
the 16th all right not being partisan at
all there's been zero progress we have
had one meeting since this conference
committee was created it was created by
Nancy Pelosi you remember she said open
the government and will negotiate she
created this committee she controls this
committee her chairmen chairs this
committee she has more votes than anyone
on this committee we've had one meeting
I've requested more I stayed all last
week went through the weekend and yet no
more meetings
well Henry Cuellar said this on Fox News
Sunday about the wall first of all we're
not gonna have a wall now can we look at
some sort of enhance barrier that's
something we can certainly look at but I
have to say living on the border you
have to let the local Border Patrol
chief have the say-so and let the local
communities be involved so they can come
up with maybe maybe some sort of enhance
barrier okay what does this look like
I'm a bit confused enhanced barrier not
a wall see through it see I always think
a wall you can't see through but we're
gonna have a see through so it's kind of
already an enhanced barrier it seems
like there's a semantic problem in part
correct well it's a little bit of play
on words enhanced barrier for the
Democrats is taking an old wall and
improving it so it's no new wall now the
president wants new walls which I agree
with
so enhanced barriers one piece that's
only it well well when you see the video
just released last week in the week
before of hundreds of people at one time
crawling across an area that I mean my
ten-year-old could crawl over this thing
this is not a difficult barrier in some
place you just walk right across the
desert very dangerous parts I think
right now you are a country when that is
how you get into your country at a place
where a lot of
want to come in that's not what a
country does it I mean if you want to
stay a country at least right sir a lot
of areas for improvement but when you
look at the plan that was presented by
Homeland Security I mean they clearly
say there needs to be new additional
barriers steel barriers walls in
addition to enhancements in addition to
technology
Border Patrol additional judges and such
there's a lot to do but a wall is a
critical component of it and I'm not
sure why they're walking away from it
well what they'll say is we're gonna do
drones and sensors and a lot of the big
interdictions are happening at ports of
entry drug interdictions so they're
they're hanging a lot of it on the ports
of entry where they are making some
progress and lower number of
apprehensions so anytime you bring it up
you're like well apprehensions are down
we don't have a border crisis you know
this is what they continue to repeat all
right well stay there and thank you so
much congressman for joining us